well Mother's Day is nearly here do you
have plans yet here's one way to
celebrate mom chocolate and Mimosas wow
Candace Charles joins us live for
methylam and Henderson with how you can
get in on the tasting experience it's
making my mouth water Candace just
looking at these chocolates tell us more
good morning guys good morning folks now
how about getting a little bit of
something for Mom that involves you a
little bit of time with her and for that
time you can have a little Mimosa not
too bad right one win and I have Lisa
vanderson here with me she is the
creative director she's gonna be doing a
little bit of the tasting here with me
of course our wonderful chocolatier
Phyllis Spire here with me as well now
I've already gone ahead and tried these
two it's like a vanilla taste really
explodes in your mouth with the peach
mimosa I've had the salty one with I
think this is a little bit of an orange
kind of flavor it kind of tastes like a
margarita we're gonna be talking about
the next two here to really show you
what the experience is like Phyllis what
are the other two here sure we'll start
there at the end so we have paired our
March family favorite the lemon satin
cream with dark chocolate with our
lychee puree and this one's really
nicely balanced because you get the tart
and the sweet together but what I really
want to tell you about is the next one
over and that is our prickly pear okay
Lisa we're now trying to this one really
quickly okay I love this piece because
it's actually inspired by our cactus
garden it's made from the fruit of the
prickly pear plant and we've paired that
with mango so you get your tart and your
fruit and also there's guava in there as
well and if you're not quite sure what
the flavors are we have this wonderful
tasting wheel that'll break those down
for you and help you identify them so
what do you suggest we do is go ahead
and put your mouth take one bite take a
bite on that one one bite put it to the
roof of your mouth let it melt and then
have that wonderful mango puree
so good you guys quite an experience
thank you so much Phyllis thank you so
much Lisa if you guys can find more
details on our website newsnow.com this
all kicks off on Sunday goes until
August 26th and just starts at 35 bucks
per person coming up we're going to be
showing you another experience you can
have along with this experience outside
but for now live from F1 Chocolate
Factory I'm Candace Charles now